Did you know that after the 1986 Chernobyl
nuclear disaster at reactor number four, that
the other reactors on that site were not shut
down permanently?
In fact, they were kept running, producing
electricity by workers who were brought in
by train every day to work on those other
reactors, the last of which was shut down
around the year 2000.
That is just one of the many surprising facts
I found out while shooting a documentary for
TV which is called Uranium: Twisting the Dragon’s
Tail.
Now while we were shooting this documentary
I would take out my little camera and shot
small pieces while they were setting up the
big camera.
This is James.
>> Hello.
>> But that has allowed me to make some YouTube
videos for you, including the most radioactive
places on earth.
And I will have a few more of those videos
coming out very soon.
But what I wanted to show you was the trailer
for this documentary.
I want you guys to check out this trailer.
Let me know what you think and I will put
at the end of the trailer the dates that this
documentary will be aired in your area.
It will be played in the US and Australia
and in Europe.
So stay tuned to the end of this trailer to
check out when it will be on in your neck
of the woods.
So thank you guys so much for watching this
YouTube channel, because without it, I never
would have got the job hosting this TV documentary.
And I really hope you enjoy it.
We put so much work into it and it looks amazing.
So check it out.
Here it is.
Legends say there is a world beneath this
one where a dragon lies sleeping.
They say: Be careful how you wake the dragon.
Around the turn of the 20th century Uranium
is almost unknown.
It is basically worthless.
But then in 40 years, just a single generation,
it becomes the most desirable and terrifying
rock on earth.
This is uranium.
And as a physicist, I am fascinated by its
unique scientific properties.
But even more so by how this one rock has
shaped the entire modern world.
Uranium changes everything.
Uranium makes the modern world.
Uranium is a dream.
Clean, limitless power.
Or a nightmare of a silent and poisoned earth.
>> Oh, it is hot.
It is hot here.
It is really hot.
>> It’s overloaded.
>> Come with me on a journey to find the most
desirable...
>> This is a nuclear reactor.
>> And the most hated rock on earth.
>> It is just that fear.
If it blows, what is going to happen to it?
>> How did we unleash the elemental force
within uranium?
What happened when we woke the dragon?
>> This is the story of how a rock changed
the world.